century is essentially Marvel's answer
to Superman even down to the big S
symbol on his costume while the details
of Rob Reynolds character make him a
very different person from Clark Kent
it's simply impossible to ignore the
resemblance at first glance moviegoers
would quickly recognize Sentry as being
Marvel's less iconic version of Superman
plus the MCU already came pretty close
with the introduction of Icarus and
eternals if Marvel ever wants to bring
Sentry to the big screen he'd probably
be best introduced as a secret weapon
kind of like Captain Marvel in Avengers
end game it's also possible that he
could be the main hero of his own
Universe that'll show up somewhere in
the mcu's Multiverse Saga either way
it'd be quite easy to set up Sentry's
arrival through minor references and
post-credits scenes like they did with
Thanos all those years ago to make a
long story short even though Sentry is a
fascinating character he would probably
wreck the MCU in multiple ways still it
would be very cool to see Rob Reynolds
portrayed by one of Hollywood's biggest
stars